[Music]
in California
whenever I wanna start a conversation
with someone I have just met one
question I always ask is what do you do
I often get one-line responses like I am
a consultant oh I am an engineer on a
recent trip back home in Ghana I started
a similar conversation on a four-hour
bus ride from a crowd the capital to
Kumasi where I come from I set up a
conversation with Kwame gentleman seated
next to me what do you do I asked he
gave me a paragraph of information and
response in fact I believe he gave me a
chapter worth of details just on a topic
of his occupation it went like this
I am a lecturer but I also operate a car
wash business on the part-time I have
recently discovered an arbitrage in
buying fish from the boat I origin and
salon in Kumasi for 50% profit margin
and my wife is helping me expand our
business for the next 30 minutes of our
ride
Kwame went on to discuss the numerous
business opportunities he is thinking of
pursuing from a sportin keshu to Germany
and processing shea butter he ended by
expressing his interest in quitting his
job as a lecturer to focus on
entrepreneurship full time at this time
I fear for him so I proceeded to tell
him why he would feel I used every
entrepreneur from what I have learned at
Stanford carefully telling him to focus
on one opportunity afterwards I took a
deep breath and we both fell in silence
for the rest of the for our journey as I
said in silence I looked out the window
and I saw the dozens of jacquez that
would rush towards our bus and every bus
stop selling us everything from
toothpaste to
snacks two former charged cars and I
began to fall into the reality of why I
was this is Africa there is a decent
amount of the population that wake up
every single morning not quite sure of
the deal of the day if it is too hot
you sell iced water if it is raining you
sell umbrellas and in a first Christmas
time you sell cookies you don't need a
business address for my business
registration or any formal training
you just need logical strategies of
survival it wasn't just about where I
was what I saw looking out the window on
a seven-hour journey in the Philippines
wasn't different from what I saw on a
two-hour train ride in India and a
seven-hour bash trip in Mexico and it
wasn't different from what I was seeing
in Ghana farmers intro revealed to me
the fabric of the local economy which I
completely ignored in giving him advice
our conversation was about the informal
economy the term informal economy refers
to any economic activity that is in law
or in practice not sufficiently covered
by formal arrangements there are 2
billion people employed in the informal
economy which is 60% of the world's
working population it is mostly present
in developing countries but it exists
everywhere else in the world in advanced
economies like the US and Europe
humanity is grappling with a fear of AI
and robotics technologies and the
question on everyone's mind is how can
we adapt to this challenge mobility
revolution my answer is learn about the
informal economy it has a place in the
world where people are experts in
embracing and artists in navigating
life's difficulties I believe learning
about a informal economy it's helpful in
preparing us towards a future
where most of us would be self-employed
yes you're currently 162 million people
was self-employed in US and in Europe
for some of them it is out of choice but
for others it is out of necessity
whichever your position is here at three
skills you can learn from people who are
working in the informal economy to help
you better prepare for the future of
work
the first skill is adaptability the
Canadian market is the largest open-air
market in West Africa and it is located
in my hometown of Massey
it has 45,000 stores made out of
concrete floors wooden slabs and
aluminum roofing sheets with a wide
variety of business activities it faces
at least three major fire outbreaks
every year after every fire store owned
as well count their losses but go back
to what the nez day like nothing
happened on one such occasion I visited
a market two days after fire gutted 150
stores I was standing right in the spot
but to my surprise there was no sign of
the fire rather fresh paint and business
as usual there are so many shocks in the
informal economy but fear and
uncertainty isn't one of them to move
forward in times of disruption we would
need to learn how to embrace chaos in
order to adapt the second skill I would
like to share is diversification one
thing that surprises me about living in
the u.s. is most people tend to focus
pretty much on one career I come from a
culture where almost everyone has a side
hustle or side gig the concept of a side
hustle is having a blend of jobs it's
like having a full-time job and a
part-time job or having multiple
independent jobs just like the street
switches from seven ice water to
umbrellas just by studying the weather
having a diversified career its
hopefully not just in shifts in the
market one thing that is very addictive
which we talked a little about is the
concept of a salary if we have an
opportunity to generate multiple streams
of income take it it changes how you
think the last kill I would like to
discuss as relationships the informal
economy is a large network of people not
connected by business cars but by trust
my mother introduces herself as a
businesswoman period but let me provide
you more details she has a 95 job as a
high school administrator and a
portfolio of side hassles she as a kid I
remember she used to work she used to
buy clothes bill of clothes and
distributing small lots to fashion shops
she later went on into coconut oil
processing and she had to develop
relationships with food chains and
restaurants to sell through them seven
years ago she came up with an excellent
idea
she wanted to travel to China to
manufacture products and important to
Ghana it was crazy I liked the fact that
she didn't she wasn't quite sure why she
would sell this time she didn't even
have a passport but just like that my
mother graduated into an international
businesswoman for someone with a
full-time job didn't even own a retail
store or a warehouse all her successes
came from phone calls and developing the
right relationships people in the
informal economy have three skills we
could all use adaptability
diversification and relationship
building
research suggests that by next year 50%
of the US workforce would be
self-employed working as independent
contractors or independent workers I
employ you to think forward
it is 2035 and we are living in the
disruptive economy we meet somewhere and
I asked you what do you do how would you
introduce yourself thank you
[Applause]
[Music]